bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vice e oggi parliamo di un
problema che affligge youtube da un po
stavolta non è un problema
dell'algoritmo l'articolo 3 no è una è
un problema
strano è partita una moda su youtube
orribile fra l'altro ho notato che da un
paio di settimane a questa parte se voi
cliccate su qualsiasi video di youtube
anche sui miei ci sono dei commenti
particolari una volta i commenti erano
tipo lascia likes è quello è bello like
lascia likes noti muore la mamma like
lascia like se ti piace ilike live oggi
i commenti sono tipo questo soldi che
troverai domani ditino imballi questo è
il ditino in basso e fantastico che va
su sui si mi piace quindi un ammette mi
piace perché
perché come se vi piace non lo so e
quindi qui c'è questo problema che a
questo problema questo dito cosi che
affligge youtube ultimamente nei
commenti visto che i commenti in realtà
servono per dibattere sul video per far
dare consigli per chiedere per l'oggi
amare non so no adesso sono tutti cosi
con cagate scritte cagate cagate tipo
soldi che troverai domani perché per
quale motivo allora facciamo una sui
miei video solo sui miei video faccio la
raccolta quindi non vado in giro solo
sui miei video vi faccio vedere il
commento i più intelligenti
subito sotto abbiamo calorie prese da fa
vj dopo questo video perché video era
ora vede le caramelle americane
ok queste sono le gioie che avrai domani
qua va bene i soldi che troverai domani
va beh cambiavo andiamo su cristiane
luna che scrivono luna il cane che
scrivono numero di ragazzi che adorano
vj non capisco il senso visti come non
capisco non lo capisco perché i commenti
cosa è diventata la vessazione commento
di youtube con sé diventata cosa
questi sono i voti buoni che prenderai a
scuola ma perché la gente metterai casta
roba soldi che perderà il tuo prof
soldi che riceverai domani i fan di
falli j
sono questi non credo siano 15 ma poi
soprattutto sarebbe molto più facile
rispondere alle domande forse se fossero
15 fanno e non avremmo commenti di
questo genere numero di gioie che avrai
nel 2019 ma poi a parte le gioie e le
gioie del 2019 sono tante ragazze
smettiamo di dire che ogni anno c'è
sempre meno gioie non è vero smettetela
certo che se iniziamo con i commenti
così già le gioie vanno a
il cap che ve ne frega di questi
commenti dategli i miei scritti a
quest'uomo chi sei fatti con dimmi chi
dimmi chi sei
ti do il mio canale ti do il pene anche
bravo bravo così si fa il numero delle
persone che piace la figlia
anche l'italiano lei si è proprio
sbattuta poco cioè nel senso lei voglia
di pensare quindi tocca qui tocca qui è
fantastico perché ti permette proprio di
dire non c'ho voglia di impegnarmi a
trovare una roba divertente quindi
schiacciate da un giorno lo scriveremo
ne hackett i commenti ci sarà solo il
nostro nickname la gente mette laica
caso non ci avevo voglia di scrivere
cose intelligenti comunque meglio un
tocca qui che le altre cagate che ho
letto numero di persone a cui piace
harry potter
almeno questo reintegrato video che lo
aveva senso però vabbè tanto stupido e
secondo me è fighissimo perché lo stato
agli universal studios di los angeles ho
dovuto bloccare questa cosa e siamo
andati ad hogwarts vedete c'è harry
potter che è quello a sinistra sono
andato ad hogwarts è stato proprio bello
per me quindi per me ricevere commenti
tipo non ri persona mi piace di potter e
nonostante la frecciatina in giù non è
male
signori miei abbiamo un'altra perla
sotto residenti vol 2 fila o finalmente
il finale di residenti vo
chissà quante persone che hanno seguito
la serie diranno ma cavolo mi aspettavo
che finisse così mi aspettavo quello o
quell'altro migliora che bello sto
nostro così come insomma sacri dibattiti
vediamo i soldi che riceverà il dato a
nonna questo mi rende orgoglioso di
farlo youtuber perché avrei proprio
dell'eas quando tu fai invitano gli sci
wow non vedo l'ora di vedere che cosa ne
penserà la gente quando lo carica di ci
sediamo alla gente cosa cosa mi dice di
questa partita
chissà se hanno notato che il boss avevo
modellato bene cioè i programmatori sono
fatti un mazzo tanto i soldi che
riceverai dato che non è una nonna è una
persona che ti regala soldi va
abbracciate lo strano né chissenefrega
dei soldi chissenefrega dei soldi anche
mia nonna mi dovessero dire piccolo non
mi ricordo di lei per quello mi ricordi
re perché faceva dei piatti di pasta che
ragazzi ragazzi piatti di pasta di mia
nonna
voglio tanto bene a mia nonna non vi
ricordate delle donne solo perché vi
danno i soldi soprattutto lo scrivetelo
nei commenti di wright identico al porco
demoni trucchi di magia o video di
unboxing frigeri con jack nobile
bellissimo questo video mi piace un
sacco mi sono divertito ci sono tanti
trucchi di magia chi sa la gente se è
curiosa di sapere come jack e riesce a
fare le le magie con le mani far sparire
apparire le cose cose che destano
curiosità quindi la magia è sempre
oggetto di dibattito perché la gente
sempre curiosa ed è per questo che la
magia anche successo andiamo a dare i
commenti tutte le persone che adorano fa
vincere
povero jack nobile il numero di por coni
che tira rai oggi beh almeno qui è il
prodotto è bellissimo ecco questo è
bello per un motivo i numeri porconi che
tirerei oggi è sotto germano mosconi
incredibile neanche a farlo apposta
questa questo neanche a farla poi questo
è venuto bene ma non per merito tuo ma
per merito suo incredibile che questa
era questa la magia jack nobile come io
è da una vita che non giocavo io sono
contento di tirarci di giocate innanzi
tutto ma di vedere tante persone che
invece come me ci giocavano e nei
commenti hanno scritto cavolo vi ricordo
di quella carta li abbiamo anche i
commenti ovviamente nel genere e poi
abbiamo i commenti dei premi nobel come
al solito queste sono le persone che
giocavano che giocano ancora a yu gi oh
io credo che yukio o non sia morto certo
va beh non come una volta ma credo che
ci siano ancora di tornare ad esempio
competitivi perché un sacco di gente
vedo che c'è non è mai andato nel
dimenticatoio totale
se ci pensate per quanto yu gi oh due
link sia veramente una commercialata
incredibile perché per comprare le
bustine digitali signori 5 euro che mi
ricordo che i pacchetti di figurine vere
di iole pagavo o così o meno comunque
meno anche tavolo come e quindi ormai è
tutto un business dietro le
microtransizioni che ci sono i giochi
gesù sarebbe figo un batterio ial di new
york tu vai in giro quando incontrò
nemico rilanci il drago bianco che
abbiamo anche cilindro magico numero di
amicizie rovinate ecco il cilindro
magico per chi non lo conoscesse su new
deal cilindro magico è una carta che si
tratta chi direttamente l'avversario ti
ritorna indietro l'attacco di back end
point e tipo come se il più 4 di uno io
ho pochi amici nella vita per quel
motivo avevo tanti cilindri magici anche
jack nobile un sacco di cilindri magici
infatti non ha amici c'è un solo io sono
amico di ginobili the binding of isaac
con marco ragazzi debba inigo vice marco
è bellissimo è nei commenti abbiamo
queste sono le ragazze che avrà lorenzo
ragazzi che cazzo ti dice il cervello
perché uno fa dei video così se poi si
trova commenti leggere perché spiegatemi
scuole che chiuderanno cosa c'entra con
le bandi cowards gesù
almeno allora vi prego
per cortesia già se fate un commento del
genere è veramente brutto nel senso
infatti vita incredibile prova per chi
se ne frega almeno fatto che c'entra
volpini tipo il cilindro magico di prima
cosa centrale le scuole chiudono con di
panico faisal
però ragazzi avevo il capo del clan
perché questo è un clown non è altro che
questo è il numero di risate che fate
vedendovi dell'ifa vj questi sono i
commenti che uno youtuber vuole ricevere
quando un aiuto per fare un video vuole
questo quindi scrivete tutti questo è il
numero del pozzo che me ne frega di
questi commenti e delle risate che vi
fate primi video vi prego scrivetelo con
queste voci perché dio mio senza e la
morte ho bisogno di questa tratte o
bisogno che qualcuno scriva nei commenti
io non so come ringraziati knapp di 308
grazie veramente questo è il numero di
volte in cui sbaglierò dire il tuo
nickname
altro commento sotto esce vai a giocare
con gli amici ciao ragione miopia che
commento era c'era già più corretto
recente vi prego scrivete un commento
decente dio mio è un video di domande ed
attive cioè di tutto da commentare non
numero di risate che vi fa fare fa
vigeva che questo il numero di persone
sono tutte questi momenti si si così si
fa bravo i the late no no non bravo cioè
no no no che poi finisce qui poi bravo i
bari va a philippe bravo the forest in
realtà virtuale uno dei miei primi sì
anzi forse il primissimo video nella
realtà virtuale che ho fatto con l'htc
rhyme molto figo e abbiamo un sacco di
commenti riguardanti appunto il guar che
sono i tuoi soldi quando farai lo
youtuber beh certamente se farai lo yeti
huber però scrivi questi commenti
l'originalità non è proprio il massimo
secondo me non facciamo tanto successo
però però li ho copiato pd fi quindi può
andarti bene abbiamo l'ultimo l'ultimo
video di oggi che andiamo ad analizzare
siccome ti va bene che gli under
simulator 2019 quelli che non leggo i
commenti li leggo i commenti porca vacca
però mi hanno proprio trincerato la vita
questi commenti di altri gelato ecco
guarda guarda questo è bellissimo questa
è l'età della morte di favi j
io ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto spero
che i commenti del genere vi facciano
capire che youtube
man mano che cresce la qualità spero il
figlio che siamo e 100 ragazzi cosa
senza mio vicino mi piace lasciato un
bel commento è un mi piace non commento
di sé nostri siti scrivete viene come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
al 16 un commento ma ragazzi
[Musica]